planned chaos you bet that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
now the Federal indictment against
George Santos for fraud
a gene Carroll's civil judgment against
Trump Harry and Megan's birthday party
for Archie
well you can count in the media devoting
hundreds of hours of coverage and
endless column inches to those types of
stories in the coming weeks and months
because those are the stories they think
damaged Trump and Republicans and
they're the stories you know the type of
stories they think will keep you
mindlessly distracted like the Santo
Saga Santos looks like he's running for
re-election are you going to support him
you're not okay so you guys will you
work to try to defeat him in the primary
Santo says
I think I think he has some other things
to focus on his life
so you don't plan to support Santos for
re-election that's what I said how
damaging is it to Republicans that
Santos at least for the time being is
going to remain in office
how damaging
is that what wolf said to the GOP hey
wolf how about an economy on the brink
of recession and a border invasion you
think that might be damaging to
Democrats
and by the way if being a fraud
disqualifies you from holding public
office
then why is Biden in the white house now
he's a long time plagiarizer and to this
day he still lies about himself I was
sort of raised in the Puerto Rican
community at home politically
it's just one of them
and it did briefly lay out the Border
crisis and the numbers are staggering
there's more than 155 000 migrants
according to U.S federal government
estimates that are on the northern
Mexico border that means they're just
sitting across from the U.S Southern
border a Homeland Security official
tells me there was more than ten
thousand Encounters of migrants just
yesterday I was reporting earlier this
week it was eight thousand so that just
gives you a sense of how quickly it's
climbing when you hear removal
proceedings yes some people will be
removed but the large majority right now
are being Mass released with what's
called an NTA a notice to appear for a
court date sometimes several years down
the road and once they have that piece
of paper it effectively works for ID for
them they're able to do whatever they
want in the country that is why they
know if they get here step foot in the
country they're good to go in the short
term at least great reporting by
malusion now we're witnessing the most
serious assault on our national
sovereignty in American history
and it's an assault carried out with the
policy help of Joe Biden and his Global
globalist Puppet Masters
now the statements they make are just as
fraudulent and certainly just as
anything goofy as George Santos has ever
said
let me be clear
the lifting of the title 42 Public
Health order does not mean our border is
open in fact it is the contrary we
believe we have a robust process to deal
with what is going to occur after title
42 lives a robust process kjp
yeah robust for fast tracking millions
of indigent illegals into America
now many of them have no valid claims
for Asylum overwhelmingly they don't
because they're economic migrants
and their sheer numbers are already so
overwhelming that they're financially
and culturally stressing our already
stressed system
or is the mayor of New York a big
liberal whose migrant hotels are filled
with crime and unrest
well is he part of the problem because
he's shipping them upstate
the Asylum Seeker issue that are hidden
the four top cities in this country
Chicago Houston New York and potentially
Los Angeles is going to undermine our
economy and the resources we should be
putting into raising our children and
families
of course that's where our resources
should be going to our people our
citizens and to those who've actually
had the Integrity to come to America
legally
but again as the angle told you last
night Biden's policies are working the
way they intended them to work
because the neo-socialist goal is to
collapse our system
they knew that when they gutted Trump's
old Border rules and lifted title 42
chaos would follow
and if they didn't know chaos would
follow then they're truly too stupid to
be in charge
now we can't even process the
immigration cases we have
did you know there is a backlog of 2.1
million immigration cases in our
immigration courts and the numbers
growing of course
oh but don't worry because secretary
mayorkas has a new plan
the bite Administration is now preparing
a memo that's going to direct Customs
and Border Protection to begin releasing
migrants into the U.S without court
dates or the ability to track them
so no piece of paper saying you have to
come back in 2028
look we all know what's being done here
it's a complete attempt to transform
America through the resettlement of all
foreigners who can pay the cartels for
passage across the border
now you might be asking when is this
going to stop
well only when Democrats are punished so
badly at the polls that they never try
anything like this again
with Democrats in power the phony Asylum
Seekers are just going to keep lining up
until life in our country is really no
better than life and let's say Venezuela
or Honduras
what we're headed toward right now is
becoming a country whose economic
picture looks a lot like Brazil's
where there's a small but very powerful
sliver of rich people and an upper class
among them protected by high Gates and
security guards
and then where most everyone else lives
in hovels just barely getting by
this crisis wasn't an accident it was
created by our leadership class
they change policies with a precise
intention to make it easier to come here
illegally
Republicans must be clear they must be
firm on this like Trump was tonight
you're going to have millions of people
pouring into our country right now at a
level that nobody's ever seen before
these people are sick anybody that wants
this to happen to our country they're
destroying our country and this should
not be allowed to happen how they're not
going to do a version of title 42 or my
title 42 which was tough we have enough
problems right now we have problems like
we've never had in the history of our
country
all Trump or any Republican frankly
should be talking about right now is the
economy and the Border
everything else is a sideshow it's a
distraction and frankly it's a trap
we're losing our country we do not have
time to relitigate Lost elections
Americans want solutions from someone
who can stop this vicious sabotage and
that's the angle hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else